toujours attaquée par l'institut de la
consommation des milliers de moteurs
diesel liban israël difficultés
politiques internes condé guînes à cause
du traité de la mort de claude dauphin
il a marqué le théâtre cinéma pendant 60
ans mes enfants d'immigrés en france
comment parvient-il à s'intégrer un
reportage dans la nouvelle
mais c'est bon soir ce sont des images
assez impressionnante je crois qu'ils
vont introduire notre journal les images
d'une éruption volcanique qui nous
révèle de bien étranges convulsions de
la terre avec le globe des formes et de
plâtre très schématiquement les
continents et que ces plaques sous
l'effet de force tellurique tantôt se
rapproche quand on s'éloigne on a pu
lire par exemple qu'originellement
l'afrique était collée à l'amérique du
sud
même chose pour l'afrique orientale et
la péninsule arabique et bien depuis
quelques jours à cet endroit là
précisément les deux continents ce sont
donc séparés d'un bon mètre et sous
l'effet de la torsion la lave a jailli
mais n'a pas jailli en mer comme cela
arrive souvent elle a jailli sur père
dans la république de djibouti
il y a une petite semaine regardez bien
cette coulée d'or de la naissance d'un
volcan à plus de 1000 degrés la lave
jaillit à gros bouillons c'est une lap
très fluide formé de roches basaltiques
pour les spécialistes c'est un signe
nous sommes sur une faille à l'endroit
où un continent crack ou de régions du
monde se sépare
il ya dix jours à cet endroit il n'y
avait rien il était plat pendant la nuit
du 7 au 8 novembre à volcan est née très
vite il atteint 40 mètres de haut
50 m de large avant-hier tout s'est
arrêté
la lave a cessé de couler alors ces
phénomènes soudain et violent font peur
n'y at il pas des risques de reprise de
l'éruption ou de tremblements de terre
pour bientôt
l'avion s'est terminée mardi dans la
soirée
elle est finie elle pourrait très bien
reprendre aussi bien dans une semaine
que dans cent ans on a mis en place un
système de surveillance pour repérer les
tremblements de terre et c'est à eux de
prendre la taille ces systèmes de
surveillance qui vous déclencherez en
quelque sorte une nouvelle alerte les
systèmes l'éruption sera précédée par
des une petite christie smic
les tremblements de terre est ce que le
fait que cette éruption se passe sur la
terre ferme et non par sous la mer comme
elles le sont d'habitude vous a appris
beaucoup de choses ils ont donc c'est
exceptionnel de rencontrer dans une zone
de séparation deux continents des
éruptions en surface de la terre il ya
deux endroits où c'est possible c'est en
islande et dans la république du mans
dimanche aidant la part on peut
approcher le volcan ainsi trahi
vous avez été près du volcan centaines
de mètres à la limite des retombées de
deux projections
c'est la république de djibouti nous a
demandé de venir pour surveiller ce
phénomène oui la république de djibouti
était inquiète de la crise sismique qui
a prévu précédé l'éruption et a demandé
à des spécialistes de venir pour voir
l'évolution
on a eu de la chance s'arrêter au bout
d'une semaine parce qu'il faut bien dire
que ordinairement ça se passe dans les
fonds sous marins qu'on ne voit jamais
ce type de volcanisme se passe en
général ça ou en séparation de tac au
fond des océans gens mais peugeot en
accusation la controverse 31 de plus de
poids quand on sait qui est la fille
thater le très officiel institut
national de la consommation alors d'où
vient la controverse et bien d'un modèle
très connue très coté l'a304 diesel
l'insee dit aux utilisateurs attention à
35 mille kilomètres vous aurez des
ennuis mécaniques et à 50000 km le
moteur rendra l'âme alors la faire vous
le voyez suffisamment grave pour qu avec
jean cau de la nyc nous ouvrions dossier
au centre de la polémique vient
d'éclater entre lienz et la société
peugeot dont le moteur diesel qui équipe
les modèles 204 et 3 104 sélections au
total 255 véhicules en un peu plus d'un
an 150 plaintes ont été adressées à
l'imc parmi les mégots dans ce
représentant de commerce représentant et
pourtant nombreux kilomètres et une 404
diesel qui a fait 256 kilomètres j'étais
très satisfait quand j'ai changé j'ai
acheté une 215 diesel break mais avec
cette voiture rapidement ses embouts 45
il avait j'ai commencé à avoir des
ennuis l'allumage l'ennui l'allumage qui
se sont aggravées à 56,8 qui va mettre à
la pub voulu démarrer et investit qu il
faut en faire le moteur changé les
soupapes et les puissants coups de 1500
francs minimum
j'ai donc faire réparer mais je suis tu
m'aimes
inquiété et j'avais demandé aux
concessionnaires de
le voir avec deux jours il a parfait
j'ai été moi même j'ai toujours aimé
pièces et à l'oeil
radi effectuent eux mais peugeot n'a pas
voulu admettre ma réclamation
j'ai donc porté ses pieds sur
laboratoire national des faits pour qui
les analyse et il m'a fait un rapport
c'est pas détaillé sur lesquels il
constaté une usure anormale des parois
intérieures et un dépôt sur les parois
extérieures qui appelle une cavitation
du moteur diesel en clair c'est un
défaut de conception du moteur qui est à
l'origine des pannes et puisque la
responsabilité du constructeur est
engagé l'insee estime que les
consommateurs ne doivent pas payer les
réparations
même si le délai de garantie est dépassé
ce qui est contesté jusqu'à présent par
peugeot qui veut bien rembourser les
pièces de rechange n'est pas la main
d'oeuvre
je crois que c'est tout simplement et
sans difficulté de procéder à un échange
standard de tous les moteurs au fur et à
mesure qu'ils se révèlent au visage
prématurément j'entendais très
naturellement c'est à dire à 52 60 mille
kilomètres ce qui est évidemment tout à
fait prématuré pour un moteur bien il
faut faire les changes pure et simple et
verser une indemnité correspondant à la
période d'immobilisation du véhicule qui
n'est pas négligeable pour une
réparation de cette nature est un
consommateur que dans cette situation il
doit d'abord faire une démarche
insistantes auprès de son vendeur c'est
évidemment ça qu'il faut faire et
s'adresser éventuellement à peugeot
parce qu'il faut essayer de régler les
choses à l'amiable dans toute la mesure
du possible
puis s'ils n'y parviennent pas que
voulez vous pour qu'ils envisagent la
voie judiciaire la justice et même là
pour intervenir lors qu'on ne parvient
pas à obtenir satisfaction et qu'on est
tout de même dans son droit
la réponse de peugeot pour l'instant la
direction de la firme s'est réfugié dans
le silence seules informations que nous
ayons pu obtenir
il ya bien quelques problèmes
mais ils ont été réglés directement avec
les automobilistes qu'à dossier qui nous
suivent en émotion chez les postiers
hier un receveur des ptt a été agressé à
marseille il en est mort tous les
syndicats réclament une meilleure
protection tous les employés de la poste
et la semaine prochaine je vous le
rappelle il y aura pendant trois jours
une sienna tournante dans les ptt
émotion aussi dans tous les syndicats à
la suite des propos de raymond barre
dans la croix sur la manière de combler
le déficit de la sécurité sociale le
premier ministre n'est pas entré dans
les détails mais nombreuses sont six se
sont émus par avance force ouvrière la
cgt la cfdt et davantage peut-être
encore la cgc qui se déclare elle prête
à une riposte immédiate si l'on aboutit
à un déplafonnement des cotisations et
puis la confirmation d'un malaise entre
la cgt et la cfdt aujourd'hui à treilles
edmond maire a estimé que les attaques
de la cgt pour donner une stratégie qui
accordait la priorité aux changements
politiques et visait à affaiblir la csdc
en matière politique maintenant à la
france se sont mobilisées et prêtes à
accueillir tous ceux des passagers du
cargo ayong qui souhaiteraient venir en
france
mais je dois avouer qu'à l'heure qu'il
est nous sommes encore un petit peu dans
l'incertitude quant au sort qui va leur
être réservé par le gouvernement
malaisien la malaisie qui jusqu'à
présent a refusé d'accueillir même
provisoirement six réfugiés sans
l'assurance qui ferait ensuite le pays
est de plus en plus à hanoi on laisse
entendre qu'on n'est pas opposé à un
départ de tous ceux à qui n'est pas le
climat politique du nouveau régime dé
samia ces réfugiés vietnamiens viendront
donc peut-être grossir les quelques 4
millions d'immigrés qui vivent en france
ce sont des chiffres dont on va beaucoup
parler à partir d'après-demain c'est
dimanche en effet que s'ouvre la semaine
du dialogue avec les immigrés parmi eux
beaucoup de portugais est d'alger n'y a
plus de 800 milles dans les deux cas
ensuite par ordre d'importance les
italiens les espagnols les marocains les
tunisiens les turcs les yougoslaves les
belges et enfin de plus en plus nombreux
plus précisément les asiatiques ils sont
plus en année
la population étrangère en france 20 77
était de 4 millions deux cent quarante
mille personnes soit 8% de la population
parmi elles 1 million 600 mille
personnes travaillent tous sont à la
recherche d'un emploi en grande majorité
ce sont des travailleurs manuels un
million cent quarante mille ouvriers
spécialisés ou qualifiés
notons que les enfants étrangers
représente 9% des effectifs de scolaires
de l'enseignement du premier degré
85 mille enfants et un peu moins un
parent étranger naissent chacun chaque
année également
quarante à cinquante mille personnes
acquièrent la nationalité française
les mesures de suspension de
l'immigration présent 1974 ont
considérablement fait baisser son volume
de 200 milles en 1970 le nombre de
travailleurs étrangers entrant en france
est passé environ 20000 l'année dernière
300 millions de francs ce jour c'est la
somme consacrée à l'aide au retour des
immigrés dans leur pays d'origine
ed institué en juin 1939
vingt mille six cents dossiers ont été
acceptés les oralité ce sont 46
personnes sont concernées lorsque l'on
tient compte de la famille des
demandeurs alors si l'on veut qu'il y
ait dialogue il faut bien sûr qu'il y
est intégration etc dès l'enfance que se
détermine la meilleure intégration
je propose de suivre en compagnie de à
l'adouber 6 et de jaloux et le reportage
qu'ils ont effectués dans deux classes
spéciales pour immigrés à paris
quel enfant n'a pas chanté une souris
verte
rien d'extraordinaire pour des français
mais si mona et italiennes mais en
france depuis trois mois seulement
son arrivée chez nous avec ses parents
du fait de sa nationalité a peut être
été moins dramatique pour des asiatiques
ou des nord africains
malgré tout tous sont des déracinés pour
ses enfants a eu riboud skull est la
première étape de l'intégration ce sera
l'école entre 6 et 10 ans ils entreront
classe d'initiation fils en existe une à
proximité de chez eux
s'il ya de la place si les parents sont
informés
une dalle et continue comme ça quand on
commet de 300 leur création en 1970 ces
classes sont aujourd'hui au nombre de
1000 les élèves ils feront un séjour de
trois mois à un an suivant leurs
aptitudes dans cette classe d'une école
parisienne du 12e arrondissement 9
nord-africains site asiatique de
yougoslaves deux portugaises une
italienne
en tout vingt ans elle ne l'a pas bien
elle cote elle parle
et puis là vous en général le temps
c'est du tout le français à part
quelques heures dans cette classe qui
sont arrivés en fin d'année scolaire
quelle est la proportion de réussite
pour ces enfants par la suite
la plupart des enfants sont installés
dans les classes fréquentées des classes
qui correspondent sensiblement à leur
âge ou alors ils ont un an de retard par
rapport à la moyenne des classes dans
lesquelles on y met et il y a trois ans
par exemple sur douze élèves qui
on vend 8 d'entre eux sont français en
plus en sixième un couple bien enviable
autres classes mes méthodes semblables
pour des enfants immigrés plus âgés
entre 10 et 15 ans lorsqu'ils ont suivi
une scolarité normale dans leur pays
d'origine
un séjour dans une classe dite
d'adaptation devrait leur permettre de
rejoindre les élèves francophones des
cours secondaire vous rendre ces classes
d'adaptation secondaires sont rares de
plus ceux qui ont la chance d'y entrer
dépasse rarement le second cycles courts
c'est-à-dire l'enseignement
professionnel une exception dans cette
classe d'un lycée du 20e arrondissement
une jeune fille désirent accéder à
l'enseignement supérieur
elle est capable de faire ça c'est dur
je vois surtout dictée c'est très bien
ça fait longtemps que tu es en france
tu parlais français en devenir tu as
pris très vite dis donc tu veux faire
plus tard en passant sans fin qui jouait
dur du venture king
les recherches effectuées dans cette
info spéciale pour enfants immigrés ont
permis de faire évoluer la pédagogie
cette science de l'éducation
cet art d'élever les enfants définition
du dictionnaire
parallèlement des enfants français
profitent des progrès détection à mieux
connaître pour mieux se comprendre ce
sera donc le thème de cette semaine du
dialogue en cours immigrés dont lyonnais
toutes les rues seraient d'état donnera
le coup d'envoi dimanche les travaux
parlementaires maintenant bien ont
travaillé d'arrache-pied en ce moment à
l'assemblée les députés ont dû force
kassé mady daniel brême il faut dire que
l'examen du budget doit se terminer
cette nuit peut-être même bercy 7 heures
du matin au menu entre autres
toujours en première lecture celui de la
jeunesse et des sports qui allait poser
prendre quand même il ya deux jours
certains députés dans leur père robert
andré vivien estime que la coupe est
pleine et qu'il faudrait limiter le
travail au palais bourbon à une heure du
matin
la pollution tante a diminué dans les
villes mais de gros efforts restent
encore à faire a indiqué cet après midi
le ministre de l'environnement michel
d'ornano qui a présenté toute une série
de mesures pour lutter contre la
pollution atmosphérique par exemple
l'abaissement de près de 40% de la
teneur en soufre du fuel suite du débat
à l'intérieur du parti communiste
l'ouvragé de nina et jean kéhayan que
vous avez pu voir au cours de l'émission
apostrophes vendredi dernier a été
interdite par la fédération des bouches
du rhône du pc lors de la fête de son
quotidien la marseillaise ce week end of
this in jean françois kahn qui prouve
bien qu'une fois de plus le débat de
dupe et sait n'est pas tout à fait
plonger je pense qu'il faut être très
franc enfin en ce qui me concerne je
comprends pas très bien si pas jouer les
faux il faut le dire tant que tel que
cela est un peu d'ail are with ça me
semble un peu confus au fond le problème
est et celui là il y ait un débat au
sein du parti communiste
à la base ce qui dit débat d'idées des
divergences d'opinion et ce à la
direction le reconnais tout à fait tout
le problème est de savoir si ce débat
est donc ces divergences on les retrouve
au sommet au niveau de la direction
et c'est cela il faut le reconnaître que
nous ne savons pas l'heure nous étions
roy raison des piliers de certains
petits fait comme ça beau redonner un
sens par exemple
voilà deux communistes membres actuels
du parti communiste nina et jean kéhayan
ils font ils publient un livre c'est un
livre où il raconte leur séjour à en
union soviétique pendant deux ans est un
livre terrible très dur mais qui
critiquent la réalité soviétique au
niveau des problèmes quotidiens de la
vie de tous les jours
vous les avez vus apostrophe la mission
de bernard pivot il était très très
agressif
le lendemain l'humanité était très
modéré dans dans l'appréciation il n'y a
pas eu de condamnation mais deux trois
jours après vous l'avais dit la
fédération communiste des bouches du
rhône alors rêve très nettement prend
parti contre c2c de communistes contre
leur livre les critiques disent ils ont
calomnié l'union soviétique qui a lutté
pour la libération des peuples à
sauvegarder la paix et comme nous
l'avions ne représente pas leurs livres
à la fête de l'humanité mais d'un autre
côté un autre contestataire a publié un
livre un conte et salers de au sein du
parti communiste vient de publier un
livre également assez musclé et celui là
il a été publié par les éditions du
parti communiste alors voilà donc ce
n'est pas un autre autre petit fait on
tente on a beaucoup parlé
le canard enchaîné cas il ya quelques
temps à étudier une information selon
laquelle monsieur georges séguy au
s'adressant au journaliste de l'humanité
aurait déclaré que le trop grand poids
du parti communiste dans la cgt serait
responsable d'un certain sectarisme de
la centrale ouvrière bien deux jours
après l'humanité dit mais non ce n'est
pas vrai calomnie il n'a jamais été
question de cela jean resseguie ne
réagit pas et non seulement réagit pas
mais il invita journaliste du canard
enchaîné à venir c'est très rare
apprenez à venir à une réunion entre
réunion il dit à peu près la même chose
alors on y voit un signe on se demande
qu'est ce qui se passe
bref si vous voulez actuellement la
situation en france politique est
difficile il y à des dissensions très
grave au sein de tous les partis en
direction de tous les partis rpr
socialiste udf et cetera
donc on aurait tendance à penser qu
aussi à la direction du parti communiste
doit y avoir des débats assez dur mais
comme vous le savez les communistes
prétend qu'il n'en est rien que le dire
c'est faire de l'anti communisme
primaire faire un complot anti copie
une proposition du sénateur henri
caillavet
un groupe de travail sénatorial sur les
concentrations en matière de presse et
notamment sur le groupe perform avec le
figaro d'aujourd'hui n'a pas paru à la
suite une aire est bien dans celui de
demain le figaro magazine un article qui
va faire du bruit les signée jean edern
hallier il s'en prend à une bonne partie
des intellectuels de gauche vous
conseille aussi la lecture d'un article
de l'express qui révèle que la
couverture radar de la chine face à
l'urss serait assurée par un matériel
français
l'autoroute a87 cette autoroute qui
devaient contourner paris est bien le
projet est abandonné a annoncé
aujourd'hui le ministre des transport
joël le theule la fin de la visite de
yano skadar à paris le numéro un endroit
invités valéry giscard d'estaing à venir
à budapest
le chef de l'état ni oui au principe
miniature de déclarations connu
président giscard d'estaing et le numéro
un hongrois veulent donner un élan
nouveau relations franco hongrois sur le
plan international les deux pays
affirment leur désir de faire progresser
la détente et le désarmement en europe
mais ce canard s'est félicité du
changement d'attitude de la france à
l'égard des grandes conférences sur le
désarmement
les français eux souligne que pour la
première fois un pays socialiste appuyé
les propositions françaises en matière
de détente dans sa conférence de presse
il ya nos skadar qui a rencontré hier
georges marchais a nié que leur
communisme déplaise aux pays de l'europe
de l'est naturellement a dit monsieur
cadart il y a une grande solidarité
entre tous les parties communes nous
communistes ont droit nous soutenons la
lutte des partis communistes de l'ouest
pour le progrès social et nous espérons
qu'elle sera couronnée de succès mais
cela reste bien sûr une affaire purement
intérieure qui ne regarde que les pays
concernés
nous sommes opposés à l'exportation de
la révolution
comme nous sommes opposés à
l'exportation de la contre révolution
en fait a poursuivi monsieur cadart la
notion de l'eurocommunisme n'est qu'une
fiction
nous avons appris à l'école que l'europe
s'étend de l'atlantique à l'oural et
donc nous aussi nous sommes européens
réaction de bonnaud critiques de paris à
propos des déclarations de la loue et de
helmut schmidt le gouvernement allemand
n'envisage aucunement de soumettre un
quelconque plan de modification du
traité de rome les relations moscou
washington il ya du mou carter a décidé
cette nuit d'envoyer ses avions espions
survolé et cuba à plus de trente mille
mètres d'altitude pour savoir si oui ou
non les mig 23 fournie par les russes
aux cubains sont équipés d'armes
nucléaires les mig 23 sont les avions
que vous voyez ici et tout cela
évidemment rappelle un petit peu les
épisodes dramatiques de 62 parce que
john kennedy était pris aux missiles
soviétiques pointés sur les états unis à
part celle de cuba
la situation paraît aujourd'hui beaucoup
moins une jolie exclusivité je crois
pour antenne 2 lundi soir un an et un
jour après le voyage historique d'anouar
el sadate à jérusalem
le président égyptien s'est peut-être
répondre aux questions jean pierre
elkabbach et d'alain duhamel dans cartes
sur table lundi donc vous savez que l'un
des problèmes qui se posent à l'heure
actuelle avec israël c'est celui de la
mention dans le traité et que les deux
pays doivent signer normalement de la
mention d'un lien avec le problème des
palestiniens l'egypte veut que le
problème de la cisjordanie soit évoqué
israël non le docteur bennani tard
l'homme droit le plus proche de menahem
begin l'a encore confirmé renard textron
important ce que les négociations en
cours porte sur un traité de paix entre
l'egypte et israël sur tout ce qui
touche aux deux pays et non pas sur la
judée la sonnerie la bande de gaza on
peut bien sûr évoqué et n'importe quoi
émotion mais
nos associations ont pour but de rédiger
un traité de paix entre l'egypte et
israël
ceci est conforme à la lettre et à
l'esprit du kmd vite on a l'impression
au site il y à des dissensions
importantes au sein du cabinet israélien
et notamment avec les négociateurs
israéliens washington l'équipe art en
cabinet n'est pas d'accord avec
weissmann et d'ailleurs nous n'en finit
pas les dissensions au sein du cabinet
bien que comme dans un pays démocratique
chaque ministre comme chaque citoyen le
droit de dire ce qu'il pense en toute
liberté
ce qu'il ya je crois ceci il faut pas le
cacher il y a des difficultés et à
l'intérieur du parlement
à l'intérieur du parti aussi majoritaire
certains pensent que le gouvernement
israël est allé trop loin dans le sens
des concessions qui l'a accepté à
l'egypte pas d'éclatement de la
coalition gouvernementale pas
d'éclatement fin de difficultés
claude dauphin n'est plus il s'est
éteint il ya soir des suites d'une
occlusion intestinale qui l'avait
beaucoup affaibli ces derniers jours
élégance finesse de son des mots qui
reviennent sur presque toutes les lèvres
pour évoquer l'acteur qui avait si bien
su renouveler son art dans une carrière
qui durera près de soixante ans saute
dauphin le frère de jean-noël 1 avec 75
parmi les 150 personnages qu'il a
interprété claude dauphin avait une
affection particulière pour voltaire de
voltaire il avait l'esprit la générosité
la vivacité et quelquefois la folie il
connaissait son oeuvre complète et il
était heureux de mettre son talent au
service du métro anvers
non je ne brûle pas me brûler comme un
livre très longtemps de ça j'avais été
malade et du possible convalescence
assez longue dans une maison de campagne
où il y avait une bibliothèque et des
constitué uniquement par les oeuvres de
voter alors élite ou voltaire 72 volume
que j'ai découvert voltaire pendant ces
trois mois je ne me suis pas arrêté de
lire et d'en être
délicieusement avis et depuis je suis
toujours c'est très ami avec lui et j'ai
toujours rêvé de jouer voltaire mon père
qui était la sagesse même et qui aimait
ses fils m'a vivement déconseillé après
montbel chaud dedans de démarrer dans
cette carrière et comme j'aimais
beaucoup ce projet était décorateur et
costumier à l'année on pendant dix ans
avant de jouer la comédie sur le vrai
côté de la barricade et à cette époque
là j'hésitais encore je me demandais si
mon avenir était vraiment dense dans la
présentation souviens que j'avais très
envie d'aller en alaska lait dans le
grand nord
ça me tentait vous ne serait ce que pour
la balade
je comprends je comprends bien dit mon
père vivait en alaska ray depuis des
années il avait la fibre aventureuse ou
et on nous sommes tous des fonceurs dans
la famille j'étais presque décidé à
partir quand j'ai fait la connaissance
d'un certain david single man vous
permettez-vous jamais après julia quand
j'étais en colère je suis pas en colère
maintenant je suis triste je réfléchis
mon chéri good toi et moi ça allait très
mal se terminer sa lettre
alors à quoi bon le temps à michel du
net avec cette histoire on fait vite le
lui dont ben voyons bah oui je vous ai
valable est contente tu n'es rien tu ne
fais rien tu n'as rien fait je ne peux
rien faire
je demande pardon mois ou une combine
pardon de quoi toi parents sont dit
qu'ont ils arrêtent le soleil
je croyais que le monde ne changerait
plus qu'il a changé je rappelle que cet
avenir que je t'avais donner autant
parler sans cesse et toi tu dois bien ça
n'était que mon passé il ya encore trop
de trains tourné son dernier film sur ce
studio même en notre compagnie titre de
ce film au bout du bout du banc le banc
s'arrêtait pour lui ce soir là notre
soirée littéraire du vendredi avec
l'émission de bernard pivot apostrophes
va commencer dans quelques minutes dans
une heure de près en prologue
voici quelques ouvrages que je vous
recommande qui sont des droits jeu la
plupart du temps de journalistes
d'hommes politiques
l'accident de maurice goldring
intellectuels communistes qui
s'interroge andré fontaine la france au
bois dormant le rédacteur en chef du
monde
le monde passivement 1
la radioscopie d'un journal par jacques
thibaud la sphère moreau racontée par un
intellectuel des italiens leonardo
chacha michel poniatowski
l'homme politique qui lui s'interroge
sur l'avenir l'avenir n'est écrit nulle
part dit il
et puis je recommande aussi trois livres
peut-être pour les étrennes d'avoir
celui de m collaborateurs georges
leclercq explique les astronautes aux
enfants celui de julien green est
particulièrement illustré dans la gueule
du temps et enfin celui d'un breton la
bretagne d'hier et de demain rappelle
maintenant des rendez vous que vous
donne la rédaction d'antenne 2 22h45 le
dernier journal ce soir présentée par
harry claude demain notez-bien 11h45 le
nouvel horaire du magazine des sourds et
des malentendants
et puis 12h30 la première édition du
week-end samedi et ni présenté par paul
lefèvre thème du magazine contraception
et démocratie alors après 10 ans
d'expérience où en est la contraception
en france et quel rapport peut avoir ce
bilan avec la baisse du niveau la
natalité est bien de questions qui sont
assez bien résumé je crois par cet
extrait d'un des témoignages diffusés
demain je suis d'un dernière d'une
famille de sept enfants mon mari
une famille de cinq enfants et vous
n'aimez pas les familles nombreuses
oui mais faut pouvoir les et mes enfants
c'est pas tout servi un sens pour
pouvoir les élever
il ordonne hamiti vous avez souffert
d'être dans une famille nombreuse
oui beaucoup mon père est mort j'avais
huit ans ma mère s'est retrouvée alexis
d'enfants qui ne travaillent pas alors
je suis très très marquée et ainsi que
les frais seraient alors vous avez pris
la décision
oui de ne pas en avoir plus de 2 demain
me dénie mais cette fois ci c'est promis
le son sera synchrone une double initial
porte-bonheur dit on est bien depuis
hier soir c'est une certitude pour
silvana suarez la nouvelle miss monde
passe très vite sur les clichés
habituels à la 20 ans 1 m 67 brune aux
yeux bruns et bien sûr elle est très
belle
alors avant de l'abandonner dans les
bras de gerard holtz sachez que la miss
travaille elle aussi à la télévision mme
à la télévision argentine
elle dirige une corde écoutez là
regardez là surtout londres le 17
novembre
ma chère maman c'est un vrai conte de
fées j'ai gagné je suis ni ce monde et
je suis drôlement ému ça doit se sentir
dans ma voix non au départ unis croyez
pas tellement tu sais enfin pas beaucoup
je veux dire qu'il y avait du monde pour
être mieux et puis finalement c'est moi
ils m'ont choisi on en fait je dois
avouer j'ai craqué
en fait
un autre agent c'étaient les nerfs sans
doute un vrai déluge de larmes
le maquillage à propos merci il a tenu
ah oui j'oubliais 6 juin un chèque de 4
millions de centimes on ne peut pas
trouver leur cursus et c'est pourquoi je
pense bien à vous en argentine on a eu
la chance continue champion du monde de
quelque chose et on voit leur ai écrit
moi maintenant miss monde et les
journalistes et qui vont parler du
respect des droits de l'homme n'aurait
répondu que la plus belle fille du monde
ne peut donner que ce qu'elle a
quelqu'un a dit me malheureusement c'est
pas compliqué
silvana suarez 20 en argentine
la passe de la météo maintenant avec des
images que vous verrez qu'ils nous
viennent de lyon
vous découvrirez un rhône qui flâne et
qui serpente son niveau un des plus bas
jamais enregistrés vous le voyez reflète
le monde de plus aux hits et symbolise
bien le beau temps qui a encore régné
sur la france aujourd'hui demain
maintenant et bien à deux zones une
moitié nord-ouest et bien entendu
accompagné de pluies est restée moi s'il
vous plaît ailleurs beau temps
ensoleillé on veut pas mais passer par
un site achève l'actualité de ce 17
novembre 78 je vous souhaite une
excellente fin de semaine à tous bonsoir
et puis à lundi